[Music]
we are very happy to present the 21st
annual space grant Massachusetts Space
Grant Distinguished Lecture this has
been going on since the very beginning
of space grant I am the director of the
Massachusetts space grant Jeff Hoffman I
guess a lot of you know me and
fortunately we have given all of you a
description of today's speakers
background so I can keep my remarks to a
minimum we are very fortunate to have
NASA's chief technology officer Bobby
Brown and the few things that aren't in
the write-up are that he got his
doctorate at Stanford University and
spent 16 years at NASA Langley is now a
professor at Georgia Tech and is
basically on leave to work at NASA and
his chief area of research is hypersonic
technology atmospheric reentry for
planetary exploration and if any of you
are planning a reentry to Planet Earth
bobby's your man so with that Bobby
we're looking forward to hearing your
talk
thank you Jeff you guys you can hear me
in the back okay what thank you for the
introduction thank you for the
invitation to be here today I'm actually
I'm really happy to be here you can only
imagine how happy I am to be here
anytime I get to go to a college campus
these days is a treat for me and while I
do love to do atmospheric entry research
at NASA or at Georgia Tech the truth is
it's been a while since I've actually
been able to do that because as chief
technologists at NASA I I deal with some
other kinds of I wouldn't quite call it
physics but other kinds of issues I want
to talk to you today about where NASA is
headed in my in my personal opinion and
through this talk I want to explain
you'll probably get a good feel for why
I left Georgia Tech temporarily well I
left Georgia Tech on a leave of absence
to go to Washington it's because I
believe in NASA and I believe in the
plan that nASA has created for our space
exploration future for exploration and
for science and I want to talk to you
about that plan here today I'm going to
talk for a little while I'm going to
give you some background I'm going to
talk about this new line in the NASA
budget called the space technology
program and what that means for all of
our futures and then I'll there'll be
plenty of time towards the end for
questions and I'd be happy to take any
questions about the material that I
cover I'd also be happy to take
questions about other aspects of NASA
that I may or may not touch on in this
talk so let me start with in the
beginning almost we've had a lot of
major anniversaries in the last few
years does anyone know what tomorrow is
anybody anybody raise your hand if you
know what tomorrow is from a historical
context
nobody knows MIT come on where my policy
people I'll give you a hint it's a
policy question
now it's not a flight President
Kennedy's speech not the most famous one
at Rice University but his speech to
Congress very important speech where he
talked about his plan to send humans to
the moon and return them safely to the
earth within the decade right a plan
that was going to measure and organize
the best of our energies and skills
that's really what it was all about to
him it was about measuring and organized
the best of our collective energies and
skills it wasn't really about going to
the moon and coming back it was about
proving the technological in that time I
would use the word superiority today I
wouldn't use that phrase but proving the
technical competence of the United
States of America President Kennedy had
a bold vision for NASA
he spoke about this vision in Congress
he spoke about this vision across the
country and when he spoke people around
the country came they heard his cry they
joined NASA they joined companies in
aerospace and they accomplished
something together that is truly
remarkable
they built rockets 37 stories high they
built engines more powerful than
anything that had ever been created at
that time and they sent 12 brave heroes
on a journey farther from the earth than
anyone had ever been before and frankly
anyone has ever been since by fusing the
imagination and creativity of their time
these young scientists and engineers
that were pouring out of our nation's
universities and going into NASA
they made a lasting imprint on this
country yes they accomplished the vision
of sending humans to the moon and
returning them safely within the decade
but they did so much more
they made an impact in our national
security landscape they made an impact
to our economic competitiveness they
created new products and services that
spun off into new businesses around this
country and created high-tech jobs they
did many things now as great as Apollo
was
I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you a little
secret it's a very personal secret but
I'll share it with you here today I
don't remember a part I don't remember
it at all I actually feel really bad
about it I should remember I'm NASA's
Chief Technologist I should remember
Apollo it was a great feat it was a it
was perhaps the major astronautical feat
of our country but I don't remember now
maybe you can't blame me I was four
years old at the time that Neil
Armstrong landed on the moon but still
in the back of my mind I think I should
be able to remember this I mean I
remember certain things from my
childhood but I don't remember Apollo
and when I go around the country as I do
now in this new capacity I run into all
kinds of people like me that are you
know roughly my age perhaps younger
perhaps in their 30s people like you
perhaps in your 20s that only know about
Apollo through the history books I thank
God for the history books by the way but
that's that's the way that I know about
Apollo and so I am a faculty member and
I do live in Georgia and if you go out I
live outside of Atlanta I live out in
the country a little bit and if you go
out in the night sky you go out at night
and you look up in the night sky in
Georgia away from the city the stars are
just amazing and I do this a lot I have
a very small farm in Georgia I go out
and I look at the night sky and I spent
a lot of time thinking about Apollo and
about you know did I miss it did I miss
the one and only time where space was
important for our country not just for
space but for economic reasons and for
national security reasons and for Global
Competitiveness reasons and I think
about well what is what is my generation
space race right you remember that
Apollo was called a space race because
we were racing against the Russians to
accomplish this goal soviet union racing
against the soviet union to accomplish
this goal the russians are now of course
our partners in space exploration and
that's also a very positive thing but I
think you know where's my Apollo where's
your Apollo and I teach a course at
Georgia Tech it's probably a lot like
the introduction airspace era last row
I guess you called your aero-astro
courses that you have here I teach an
introduction to aerospace engineering
course and one of the things I do with
the incoming freshmen is we talk a lot
about why are they going into
engineering why in particular are they
going into aerospace engineering and we
talk about their hopes and their dreams
of their careers and so I want to share
with you today my list this is not a
NASA slide by the way this this next
slide this is my personal view of
potential futures and these futures are
not so far away by the way this is a
slide that I made for my as I said for
my introduction to aerospace engineering
class at Georgia Tech this is a slide
that I made long before I was back at
NASA as the chief technologist these are
nine you can call them paradigm changes
or game-changing possibilities for our
civil space program these are nine
things that I honestly believe are
within our grasp
technologically there they might be just
outside our grasp today but in my
lifetime I believe that we as a nation
could accomplish these things and
there's some pretty lofty goals here was
it you know without going through the
whole list being able to predict or
forecast major storms in natural
disasters but in time to move the
population out of harm's way that's
something that you know there are is
example after example after example very
in our very recent past of where such a
capability would be of tremendous value
think no further back to just a few
weeks ago in Japan or any time you know
in the last few years you can think of
several examples there
think about our Astra you know an
asteroid defense system we all know
there are lots of asteroids we know
there are lots of
earth crossing asteroids are in
asteroids in Earth's vicinity we also
know that at one point in time one of
those asteroids it's a very low
probability event but at some time one
of those asteroids will come our way
what separates us from the dinosaurs we
have a space program we should be ready
to deal with that event we can develop
engineering mitigation strategies today
or in the next decade for such an event
the search for life I think this is you
know in the sciences this is one of the
most profound questions that one could
ask you are we alone I've actually
worked a lot in the robotic program in
particular the program that has sent
spacecraft robotic spacecraft to Mars
and our robotic Mars program has
progressed from the search for water to
the search for carbon a search for
habitability if you will and we're
moving slowly and carefully to the
ultimate goal which would be the search
for life at Mars or elsewhere in the
solar system I'll tell you something
else that fascinates me earth-like
planets around other stars how many
years ago was it when if you said I
think there are like planets around
other stars
you had no proof you've had nothing just
a thought
probably you know based on probability
you could argue it made sense but you
had very little data we now have
hundreds of examples of planets around
other stars many of which are in the the
right zone from a temperature
perspective many of which have we
believe a rocky core as technology
advances we will be able to redefine
what an earth-like planet means so that
it actually over time it becomes more
and more earth-like now these aren't
just some professors dream these are
things that we can actually do these are
things that are called for into some
regard or another in in decadal surveys
by the science community these are
things that are lower on my list I have
some human exploration examples
involving commercial industry involving
expanding out beyond low-earth orbit
these are things that
been called for in study after study
after study of our human exploration
program there are all kinds of plans and
roadmaps on how we might go about doing
these things so you might ask what's
holding us back
maybe we're not making investments in
the technology needed to enable our
future that's my hypothesis if you will
I actually believe it to be true
I can show you that with a number of
examples but for the past decade or more
nASA has not made the advancements in
technologies required to enable those
future missions
yes nASA has accomplished great things
over this past decade over the decade
before that NASA continues to do so in
earth science in planetary science
heliophysics actually across all the
sciences NASA continues to do great
things in human exploration I mean look
at the International Space Station if
there ever was an engineering marvel the
International Space Station is it if
there ever was a model of what we as a
world can do together
the International Space Station is it so
we have done great things and we
continue to great to do great things but
we won't be able to do the things on
this list or in my opinion on your
individual lists without these
investments in technology so let me give
you an example one that I know something
about from this list let me talk for a
minute about what I what has always
excited me which is certainly a grand
challenge which is the idea of one day
sending humans to the surface of another
planet in fact to the surface of Mars
this is something that I've studied in
fact coming out of a kind of me out of
Penn State as an undergraduate I
actually was hired by NASA and the
reason I took the job at NASA was
because they asked me to work on sending
humans to Mars I had three or four other
job offers I went to NASA because they
said if you come to us we're gonna have
you work on humans to Mars I mean come
on where else are you gonna go right
with an offer like that but it didn't
matter that the pay was significantly
less by the way I still I still
went for it so this is something that
I've studied and I'll tell you something
else this is something that for on a
much smaller scale of a robotic missions
this is something that I've done I've
been a part of several teams these are
national teams that involve people in
California and Colorado and some folks
here in Boston I was in Virginia at the
time I've been involved in teams that
have landed robotic spacecraft can you
guys see that okay okay that have landed
robotic spacecraft on the surface of
Mars and I'll tell you there's no
greater feeling if you're an engineer if
you've been working on a project like
this for four or five years to actually
see that project come true I worked this
is a Mars Pathfinder Mars Pathfinder was
the first mission to the Mars surface
since the Viking missions of the 70s now
funny as it may sound to you I actually
remember the Viking missions I was older
than there was a lot of work at the
Goddard Space Flight Center which is
right outside where I grew up so some of
my neighbors worked on the on the Viking
missions and I think there's some poetic
justice that the first mission I ever
worked on was Mars Pathfinder the first
mission to land on Mars in 20 years
since those Viking missions that kind of
got me excited about NASA in the 70s my
job by the way was to land the
spacecraft my job was to help get him to
the to a safe spot and land them safely
in fact when this image came up for Mars
Pathfinder on July 4th 1997 before the
rover was deployed before any science
could be done I was through my job was
complete I walked out of the Mission
Control Room you know like this
high-fiving everybody that I saw as the
scientist poured into actually start
start their work I worked on a couple
thank you oh yeah it was a big team by
the way and that was maybe the best part
of the job was being on that team I
should say I went from working on Mars
Pathfinder to working on a few other
missions some of them have succeeded
some of them have actually failed and
one thing that I do want to say is that
part of the journey is the learning
and I learned much more on those Mars
missions that failed the ones that we
don't talk about anymore the ones that
are you know back that in the press got
all the the bad words associated with
them I learned much more on those
missions that failed than I did on the
ones that succeeded so I'm going to come
back to that in this talk when I when I
get to risk-taking but that's something
to think about now I know how hard it is
to land Mars Pathfinder remember the
Mars Pathfinder Rover was about this big
about the size of a baby if you will and
I know how hard it is to land the Mars
exploration Rovers which are about the
size of those small cars that your your
kids might drive around in the driveway
you think about that and I'll tell you
that right now NASA is working on the
Mars Science Laboratory it's going to
launch later this year it's going to
land in 2012 it's a fantastic mission
I'm not part of the team that's involved
in landing that mission I only wish I
was a part of it because it's so cool
they're gonna land a rover the size of a
small car weighing an amazing one metric
ton okay this is this is a fantastic
mission it's going to do some great
science okay but when I look at MSL and
I think about how hard it is for this
team of people around the country to
figure out how to land one metric ton on
the surface of Mars and I go back to the
studies of human Mars exploration that I
worked on right out of school and that
have been done since it's like crossing
an ocean I mean it's it's a whole
different game here in the bottom part
of the slide I have a graphic an
artist's depiction of what human Mars
mission might look like we would send
our astronauts down to the surface not
in a car size Lander but in a two-story
house and we would land that two-story
house right next to another two-story
house that's been landed autonomously it
has been powered up has produced all the
consumables and fuel and propellants
that the astronaut Explorers need it's a
it's a fully fueled up base camp if you
will complete by the way with a car in
the garage and all the way to the right
of this image I've superimposed the
largest human spacecraft Lander
ever built going back to the lunar
excursion module you recognize it it
doesn't belong on Mars it would never
land on Mars as this is a Photoshop
trick I've just put it there for scale
but I want you to think about that scale
difference and more importantly I want
you to think about the one metric ton
number versus on the right-hand side of
that screen 40 to 100 metric tons of
stuff that we have to land now the way
we land now we land with heat shields
and arrow shells and parachutes
sometimes we use airbags we use a little
bit of propulsion subsonically we use
some navigation techniques almost all of
those things go out the window because
of this scale difference they don't
scale very easily with mass they might
scale but they'd have to be so big and
the time required to let's say deploy a
parachute would be so large that we
probably hit the ground before the
parachute was fully deployed just to
give you one example so the question is
how do we land something this big
another way of looking at this there you
go another way of looking at this same
problem is in terms of the mass required
to leave earth for this mission if we
have for human explorers and we want to
send them on a round-trip mission to
mark to the Mars surface all right we
want to send them to Mars we want to
turn them safely it's not a one-way trip
and we use current technology and I'm
going to define current technology as
technology that's been proven in space
today okay it's already been proven
stuff we have in hand it's the things
that NASA would consider low risk so
it's predominantly chemical propulsion
both for leaving the earth and for
arriving at Mars and for leaving Mars
and coming back to the earth if we were
to do that one round-trip mission the
amount of mass required for that mission
is shown on the y-axis here and I've
broken that I've chunked that mass if
you will a couple of different ways so
you can kind of get a feel for how large
this number is it's 12 International
Space Station's okay think about that
for a minute it's taking us the better
part of a decade to launch and assemble
one International Space Station
I'm here talking to you about now is 12
International Space Station's and by the
way this is the mass just to be clear
this is the mass in low-earth orbit it's
not the mass on the ground so we have to
launch 12 International Space Station's
of mass most of which is propellant by
the way into low Earth orbit we have to
assemble it put it all together keep it
deal with boil off during the time
required to assemble this ship if in
launch in terms of launches remember the
most powerful rocket ever constructed 37
of them 37 Saturn fives Saturn 5 doesn't
exist anymore but if we had it 37 Saturn
fives for this conventional you know in
hand technology approach to sending
humans to Mars so what do we need to do
to make this mission feasible since I'm
the chief technologist you probably have
already guessed the answer we need to
invest in technology and here's this
same mission this is the impact in terms
of mass on that mission if we make
various technology investments the first
one that I've shown here is improving
cryogenic boil off right if we you know
because most of this mass is propellant
we don't want that mass of that
propellant mass boiling off if we make
advances there we can have a we make a
big dent in the amount of mass required
and low Earth orbit we go from 12
international space stations down to 6
but guess what
there is no single technology advanced
that can get us to in the realm of
feasibility for a human Mars mission and
so what we really need is a number of
technology investments we need a series
of technology advances across multiple
disciplines to make a human Mars mission
feasible and by the way when I say
feasible it's still hard some people
would say it's still DARPA hard I would
say it's still NASA hard it's a couple
of International Space Station's now the
reason that I'm excited about this chart
and the reason that I'm excited about
saying hey it's only two International
Space Station's I know that's more than
we've done before but it's at least
within spitting distance of something
that we have accomplished one
International Space Station at least at
this point I can make a cogent argument
to
folks in Congress to policymakers at
least at this point policymakers can
make a cogent argument argument to the
American public that remember pays for
our space exploration program that this
is something that we might be able to do
I didn't say that we can do something
that we might be able to do as long as
it's up at the 12 international space
stations
I might as well not broach the argument
in my personal opinion okay and this is
the power of technology you guys have
seen it time and time again in your own
lives think about your first computer
right how big and bulky it was it came
in a suitcase if you can remember that
day that you had to lug it around a
suitcase and now people are you know
walking around essentially with a
computer in their pocket that they also
talk talk to their friends on and you
know do music and movies and all kinds
of things right that's the power of
technology and that same power of
technology can help us in human
exploration it can help us in the
science missions that the decadal
surveys have called out it can help us
across the board in all nine of those
areas that I have that I had on that
list previously but it will only help us
if we make the investments today to
enable our future missions and that's
really what the space technology program
is all about
so as NASA's Chief Technologist I have
the responsibility for all technology
matters across the agency I don't
control the budget for all the
technology across the agency it's split
up and there are people called mission
director and associate administrators
that control different portions of
NASA's budget but I report to the NASA
Administrator and I have kind of a
policy view of all the technology
investments NASA's making whether
they're for the science missions whether
they're for Aeronautics whether they're
for human exploration and one of the
things that we've done is we created a
new program a new set of programs that I
want to describe for you here today
called space technology this space
technology programs are a part of the
2011 budget process and they're also in
the President's request for 2012 the
reason that that this line
shown up now is because this
administration is very committed to
making investments in research and
development making investments in
technology and innovation because this
administration believes that that is the
key to our economic future that's the
key to high-tech jobs that's that's the
key to global competitiveness there are
all kinds of not just science and
exploration benefits but there are
national security and other benefits as
well for these kinds of investments now
if you go all the way back to the Space
Act when NASA was officially put into
being it says very clearly that NASA was
put into being for three reasons
to focus on three what I would call
longstanding core competencies one
research and technology to flight
systems flight hardware development
three mission operations and when I
think of NASA it's actually the
integration of those three long-standing
core competencies that makes NASA such a
unique and special place in the federal
government there there are three legs of
a stool if you will and all three of
those legs are critical you take any one
of those legs away and NASA's not NASA
right I can't imagine NASA without
flight systems without launches I can't
imagine NASA without operations in space
right it's not I don't want NASA to be
NSF for example let's focus exclusively
on research and technology but I also
can't imagine NASA without research and
Technology and what this line space
technology line is all about is about
rebalancing the agency back towards its
original Charter towards a balance
between research technology flight
hardware and mission operations now when
I say balance I don't mean that we're
going to spend an equal amount
budgetarily we're obviously going to
spend far less on research and
technology than we are on flight
hardware or Mission Operations because
those things are expensive and that's in
my honest opinion that's the way it
should be but we have to spend within
NASA a critical mass we have to spend a
critical amount on research and
technology that allows NASA to have a
critical mass to advance
our future otherwise the agency's
spinning right it's not it's being it
become very incremental and those
missions that I'm talking about in our
future would remain forever in our
future so the space technology program
is about balancing NASA it's about
enabling our future in space by
investing in those high payoff
disruptive technologies that frankly
industry cannot tackle today this has
always been the role of the government
right to take to attack the basic
research to focus on foundational
research that that would then spin out
into future industry capability or
future missions for NASA that means
technology that enables our future
science and exploration missions it also
means a great ability to partner and
leverage the space investments being
made by other government agencies and
there are many other government agencies
making investments in space and it also
means enabling the commercial space
sector to do more and more over time in
space another great reason to invest in
technology is because it keeps you at
the cutting edge right why are you here
at MIT you came to MIT I would imagine
to get a great education but you also
came to MIT because you know there are
professors here that are at the cutting
edge in their fields by investing in
research and technology NASA will remain
at the cutting edge and lastly as I
mentioned just like in the Apollo
program these kinds of investments these
kinds of long-term goals are a great way
to stimulate economic competitiveness
and to build our to build our nation's
economy our global competitiveness
through the creation of new products new
services new businesses new industries
high-tech jobs ok now let me tell you a
little bit more about space technology
space technology actually consists of 10
programs it's a series of programs and
if you know anything about technology
readiness levels it's they spanned all
the way from TRL of 1 which is on this
slide all the way on the left to TRL of
say 7 which is all
on the right in words what that means is
they go all the way from concept to
flight so if you have an idea if you
have a technology that you think is
important to the future of the aerospace
community whether it's a concept whether
it's something that needs to be tested
in a lab or in a ground-based facility
whether it's something that's mature
enough to be demonstrated in the
relevant environment of space there's a
space technology program for that idea
these ten programs my organization is
managing these ten programs in three
divisions and those divisions are shown
on the bottom of this slide the low TRL
stuff or the the concept kind of stuff
is in early stage innovation the
laboratory and ground-based testing work
the stuff that you need to prove the
experiments that we do to prove that the
fundamental physics are valid right you
know I have a great idea it looks great
on paper but there's always like this
nagging a little bit of physics that
might be holding you back the way the
way where you're going to go to prove
that fundamental physics is valid is in
game-changing technology and if you're
that you show that that fundamental
physics is valid in cross-cutting
capability demonstrations we will take
your technology and demonstrate it in
the relevant environment of space maybe
it'll be a secondary payload I'm able to
be a hosted payload it may even be have
a dedicated mission depends a little bit
on what we're talking about so on the
top of this slide the way I think about
is I think about it as a funnel a funnel
of ideas that are open to the broad
community industry academia government
this is all being done in a competitive
manner so you you'll basically write a
proposal that documents your idea your
idea will be evaluated through a
technical peer-review process just like
we use in the science Mission
Directorate by the way and should your
idea be selected you would get funding
to advance that technology through one
of these programs on the early-stage
side of the house an early stage
innovation there'll be lots of ideas
right these are these tend to be kind of
low dollar value Awards you know
universities will certainly have a large
role in early stage
innovation and as you go to the right
you know not all of those great ideas
will pan out you know I am a I am a
dreamer but I'm also a realist not every
great idea I had was really a great idea
some of them through ground-based
testing through laboratory testing will
show that they're not quite ready for
primetime and they won't go forward
others will move forward and get all the
way to flight we'll also work with the
NASA mission directorates with other
government agencies and with the
commercial sector all through this
process so so that when we demonstrate
that your technology is flight ready
there'll be a customer there waiting to
infuse it on a future NASA mission or a
future commercial mission or a future
other government agency mission so maybe
the best way I have of describing this
program is through this little video
where a few people that have been
developing this program I'll talk to you
about these different stages so we'll
watch that for them when I think of NASA
I think of an agency focused on
technology at the cutting edge
[Music]
instead of telling people the specific
idea that they need to work on what
we're gonna do is set grand challenges
for our technological pace
what we're gonna be looking for our
visions of the future
[Music]
the first stage is called early stage
innovation it's a new idea how do we
assess how practical it is how feasible
it is how NASA can use it who can use it
we have a funnel and many concepts come
in from many directions they have to get
a chance there's to be some vetting a
few will actually turn out to be worthy
of further study further study usually
involves more effort and more expense so
we can't do it for all of them but this
is the initial gate where we try to give
those ideas a chance and we hope one of
them is going to change the world
the next stages game-changing
technologies a game-changing technology
has the ability to change a customer's
expectation in a profound way
many ideas die because it's very
expensive to transition from small-scale
laboratory to a large-scale mission
typically in NASA we provided a solution
in the game-changing program we're going
to actually provide a capability that we
need leaving it open to innovation and
high risk technologies to be proposed
rather than than the classic way that
NASA has done it and once that high risk
technology has been proven out then it's
more readily acceptable to a mission
[Music]
once the technology crosses the
game-changing hurdle I would be brought
in to cross cutting capabilities
demonstration to be demonstrated in
relevant environment we also want to
think outside the box where we're doing
things a more streamlined and efficient
manner like testing it on an aircraft or
suborbital platform like a sounding
rocket or even on the ground here a test
chamber or a lab and NASA needs to be
able to collaborate by getting the
expertise that exists at various NASA
centers industry academia other
government agencies we could actually
try to broaden from a low maturity level
to a mid maturity level to a high
material level and look at multiple
partners and customers that would be
interested in technology
[Music]
we're not developing technology just
playing our sandbox we're developing
technological solutions to real problems
for the United States to position itself
as a leader in the future we have to
lead through technology these are grand
challenges for the agency these are
grand challenges that will engage the
nation this is what NASA was built for
and these are the things that we can do
through technology investment
[Music]
okay all right so so the space
technology program exists to fund your
ideas not all of your ideas will be
funded I gotta be clear about that
but it exists to fund innovators around
the country I'll tell you I've traveled
all around the country over this past
year and I'll tell you one thing is a
certainty this nation is not short on
innovation this nation is not short on
innovators we're short on ways to fund
our innovators and space technology was
created as one way particularly for the
aerospace community to do that now what
are the benefits of this of this funding
the benefits to NASA are very clear I've
mentioned them to some extent already
the benefits are for our future human
exploration missions and our future
science missions in human exploration
here are a couple of artist concepts
whether we're talking about humans going
out to an asteroid whether we're talking
about in the lower right hand corner
humans
inserting into orbit or landing on the
surface of Mars whether we're talking
about propellant depots in the lower
left-hand corner or deep space
exploration spacecraft in the upper
right hand corner these vehicles these
systems will look nothing like the
vehicles and systems that we have
already created they will look nothing
like the vehicles and systems that were
created with 1960s and 1970s technology
they would look nothing like the Apollo
vehicles and systems in my opinion if
they if they look that way then I
already know what they will cost and if
they cost that much they will not exist
okay so that's why I can say what I'm
saying with some certainty I can't tell
you when these vehicles will exist when
these systems will exist but I can tell
you when they exist they will use new
technologies and they will look
different
then we might think they look today
based on existing or older technologies
that's true in human exploration and by
the way I do want to focus on the
International Space Station for just a
minute the International Space Station
as I said earlier is an amazing
engineering achievement I I can't think
of a greater engineering achievement you
guys here at MIT I think know a lot
about the International Space Station
you're very proud of mi t--'s role in
that in development of this system and a
lot of faculty here have had various
roles in that it's just it's a
tremendous laboratory it's been recently
designated a National Laboratory and
it's a place where NASA is now planning
to do research and technology it's a
unique environment a controlled
environment from where where we can do
microgravity research and technology we
can learn about long-term long-term
human degradation in space right we can
also demonstrate technologies that have
to last for a long time as well I know
that you're very familiar with the
picture in the lower right so I won't
talk too much about that but in the
upper right you see the water
reclamation facility that is currently
flying on the International Space
Station this is a station a facility
where they can take wastewater and
convert it in drinking water right as
you can imagine water in space is a
precious resource so that's a very
important thing to be able to do on the
International Space Station and it's
certainly a very important thing to do
for our long-term human exploration
plans but that's a technology that also
could have immediate benefits here on
the earth think about all the places in
the world where water is a precious
resource where there's not enough water
for people to survive and think about
spinning off that technology into some
company it won't look exactly like that
it won't look anything like that
actually but think about taking that
technology and using it here on the
earth for non-space purposes
in the lower-left here I have a picture
of my best friend Robonaut Robonaut is
currently flying on the International
Space Station
I was developed through a partnership
between NASA and GM some of you may know
a great deal about Robonaut Robonaut is
flying in space and is going to be
demonstrating over time more and more
complicated tasks human robotic
interaction type task is going to be
offloading the astronauts so the
astronauts have more time to do science
to do what humans do best and at GM
plants some GM plants around the country
you're going to see robotic assistance
that look something like Robonaut may be
a little bit different starting to work
in our factories working alongside
factory workers you may or may not know
this unless he studied the automobile
industry but the automobile industry
pretty much partitions their factories
into spaces where humans work and spaces
where spaces where robotics take place
because robotic and humans in close
proximity there's a there's a safety
issue there in some of the factors
Robonaut was designed specifically to
work with humans and that's GM's
interest right so this is a technology
that we developed for the space
exploration program that is also going
to pay dividends for one particular
company at least right here in this
country for our science missions there
are all kinds of benefits pick up any
decadal survey and think about the
missions that are called for by that
group of scientists these missions are
not easily done think about how hard it
has been for us to do the Mars Science
Laboratory think about how hard it will
be for NASA to complete the James Webb
Space Telescope okay beyond that the
scientists want to do more and I don't
blame them I want to do more - I still
have questions every time we fly a
mission I have more questions okay so
what this is is three depictions of some
future telescope right say you wanted to
construct a really large aperture
telescope or large aperture antenna
in space there are many ways you might
do that you might fold the thing up so
that it fits in the launch vehicle take
it up into space and deploy it you might
fly a constellation of smaller systems
smaller apertures that go in formation
flight and form a larger aperture or you
might have a segmented set of mirrors
that deploy and to a precision optic
tolerance in space there are many ways
that this large system could be
constructed how do we know which way is
the best the only way we'll know is if
we invest in each of these pathways at
least for a little while do some testing
and figure it out that's what research
and Technology is all about it's about
figuring out the future path for a
future mission and the technologies that
we're going to invest in through space
technology are going to pay very large
dividends for our future science
missions now these missions that we're
talking about doing they have tremendous
value for our they have tremendous value
for our not so good for our future
aeronautics science and exploration
missions but they also have
down-to-earth applications I'm gonna let
that go
think about the Gulf oil spill did you
may or may not know that that spill was
tracked the boats were sent the rescue
was coordinated by spacecraft flying
overhead think about the rescue of the
Chilean miners that work was that that
rescue was actually conducted by the
Chilean government but they got a lot of
advice from NASA from the biomedical
expertise at NASA on how to keep those
miners safe when they were trapped
beneath the surface and how to extract
them with a structure that looks
surprisingly like a launch vehicle or a
capsule think about all the technologies
that come from space think about your
use of the Weather Channel your GPS on
your phone the blood pressure monitoring
devices that the biomedical industry
uses LASIK eye surgery the
Wow the protective armor that keeps our
police firefighter and firefighters and
military personnel safe many of these
things have come from space technology
they've come from our investments in
space and they've been spun off into
products like get this thing to work
into products right here on the earth
these down to earth applications help us
and they also create jobs they also
create companies they also create
products and they also stimulate our
economy nASA has been tracking these
things for a number of years we call
them spin-offs and you can go to my
website the office of the chief
technologist website and you can search
to your heart's desire about all these
spin-off applications that have come
from investments in space you can find
out about the nutritional supplements in
baby formula or the impact we've had on
golf clubs or other athletic we're about
how space technology affects eye exams
and other biomechanical issues you
probably don't even know the large
number of everyday applications that
come from the space program that come
from investing in space technology this
is something that NASA hasn't done a
great job of in my opinion of
communicating and this is something that
we're going to do a better job on in the
future so when I think back on that
original question that I posed for you
that hypothesis that what is our
generations space race what I keep
coming back to is it's the same it's the
same as it always was
it's about technological leadership I
would posit that that's what the Apollo
program was actually all about it wasn't
maybe phrased that way but that's what
it was all about and I would posit that
that's what it's all about
still today we may not be in a race we
may be more of a collaboration and and
actually I think that's a good thing but
there's no doubt that this nation's
future is dependent highly highly
dependent on the investment
we make and the leadership position that
we take in technology and so it's really
for those reasons that I you know took a
leave of absence from Georgia Tech went
to NASA and I'm currently serving as the
chief technologist these are the kinds
of things that I think about every day
as I'm planning the space technology
program and these are the kinds of
technology applications that I think you
will see if you want to if you choose to
participate in the space program or just
over the advances that we will make in
the next decade or the next two decades
all right with that I'll just I'll just
pause right here this is the website
that I mentioned earlier if you want to
learn more about this stuff more about
the programs that I'm talking about more
about the applications more about NASA's
future missions this is a great place to
start and I'd like to see if there are
any questions thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah I was wondering there didn't happy
any talk about going back to the moon
potentially with the space base on the
moon permanent in advance of going
tomorrow like we're just going to Mars
it makes sense from a commercial point
of view space tourism couple other in
this piece very binding both to the moon
first
test some science develops of science
technology and they go to Mars yeah I
didn't mean to imply that we're going
straight to Mars okay I was using Mars
as an example just to be clear I was
using Mars as an example because it's
something I know something about
something that I've worked on it's
something that I personally am very
interested in what NASA is really doing
is we're building you know through
technology investments we're building
the capability required to be deep space
explorers and whether we go to the moon
first whether we go to an asteroid first
whether we go to the to orbit Mars and
then go down to the surface you know
almost regardless of the order or the
next destination
we need these capabilities the president
actually said in almost a year ago in
April of last year at the Kennedy Space
Center the president laid out a set of
destinations and the destination that he
challenged NASA with was to take humans
to a near-earth asteroid by 2025 to have
humans in orbit telle opera teller
robotics of robotic explorers on this on
the surface of Mars to have humans in
orbit about Mars by 2030 and to have
humans on the surface of Mars at some
point in his lifetime he didn't actually
give a date for that I was encouraged
because we're about the same age and and
I figure maybe that means in my lifetime
but you know it's hard to know but
you're right there are there are a
number of people that have different
plans some people believe that going
back to the moon is the next step for
for commercial reasons or for
exploration reasons that we haven't
finished exploring the multi
others believe that we've been to the
moon and it's time to go someplace else
to an asteroid for instance 2030
objective for human exploration I mean
I'll take it for you in chunks if you
will in this next chunk of time and I'm
not going to give you a number okay but
in this next chunk of time for human
exploration we're going to be focused on
a couple things we're going to be
focused on full utilization of the
International Space Station that's
number one right we spent a decade
constructing this thing it is an amazing
engineering laboratory and we spent a
lot of our taxpayer money constructing
it it's time that we utilize the
International Space Station for science
and for technology at the same time that
we're utilizing the International Space
Station we are going where we are
building through the commercial cargo
and Commercial Crew programs we're
building the capability in this country
to have cargo and then one day
astronauts lift it up and down to the
station to low-earth orbit by commercial
industry okay and the third piece that
we're working on in this first chunk of
time this is all simultaneous is we're
building the deep space exploration
elements that we know we need we know we
need a crew vehicle that's capable of
keeping humans safe for a long period of
time in space for to go to deep space
and we know we need a large launch
vehicle to send that crew vehicle and
whatever other cargo and and things are
required in the deep space and so we are
in parallel developing all three of
those systems
now with those systems in hand we'll be
able to make in my opinion a very
informed decision rather than just
picking a destination we'll be able to
make an informed decision about what is
the right next step is it the moon or is
it an asteroid or is it direct to Mars
and I'm not I don't want to get into an
argument with you about that because you
know different people have different
views of the strategy
[Music]
be released biography of the man
legally amongst other things will I
think they deliver the murder in 1985
have any knowledge at all
you're writing this biography at the
factory
no I have no knowledge of that I'm sorry
if I did I would tell you okay yes sir
in the state lawmakers have assaults
like science fiction because because of
[Music]
clear I mean interstellar robotic
exploration but it is something I
believe in and yes it sounds a little
bit like science fiction oh I'll give
you that there are lots of things that
we have today that sounded like science
fiction not very long ago right when I
was a kid I watched Star Trek and they
had this thing called a communicator
right and the very first phone I had was
one of those Motorola flip phones
you remember those flipped them open
just like a communicator I never thought
when I was a kid that I would have such
a device and now we all have them okay
and there are mean that's just one
example because I have this you know in
my pocket here you're right
interstellar robotic spacecraft will
either take a very long time to get
there it could be even a generational
kind of spacecraft a spacecraft that
transforms itself over time there are
there is a lot of research going in into
regeneration of materials reuse and
regeneration of materials in flight
that's a possibility there's also a lot
going on in propulsion some of that
propulsion is on the border of what I
would call science fiction in science
fact
but you know it would take something
like that to make this mission to make
that kind of mission to reality it's
also true that not everything that not
all stars are equal there are some
closer and some farther so it depends a
little bit on the target that we're
talking about as well
any other questions yeah so propulsion
as I stated earlier you know to date and
for the past large number of years nASA
has been very counting very much on
chemical propulsion your standard if
it's LOX hydrogen you're talking about
an ISP in the 400s there are other
technologies out there right there's
there's low thrust that we use we could
use to position cargo including
propellant stages around the solar
system for humans use or for our robotic
missions whether it's nuclear electric
or solar electric and there's nuclear
thermal nuclear thermal propulsion has
been around for a while it's nothing new
it was actually developing ground
demonstrated in the 70s right here in
this country and it is something that
time and time again in studies of human
Mars exploration people have shown to be
very beneficial it's something that you
know takes us from let's say 12
international space stations in my
example down to something like six or
five very quickly just with that one
technology it's a big bike it is
something that NASA is interested in it
is something that NASA is pursuing
through the technology development
programs we're going to pursue it first
in a non-nuclear way there are a number
of technologies involved in nuclear
propulsion that can be demonstrated with
similar with simulants if you will our
simulators of the nuclear material and
of course for NASA to fly anything
nuclear in space there's a whole very
large and long series of approvals that
would have to be granted so this isn't
anything that's going to happen anytime
soon I should point out though just for
full disclosure NASA does fly a very
small amount of nuclear material on its
robotic spacecraft we do that today
we've done that in a number of missions
in the past
and will continue to do so because there
are cases as you get farther and farther
from the Sun it's really not just an
efficient way in some cases it's the
only way to do these deep-space
exploration programs so it is something
that we're interested in and you'll see
it called out very clearly in in some of
the work that goes on as early as next
year through these technology programs
new idea development - sort of changing
cross-cutting technologies to sort of in
the space environment protect
demonstrations how does how does Space
Station fit into that
are all space nation experiments sort of
considered at the right end of that or
not
all the way across the next space
station so the question was in the
spectrum let me I can even go there if
I'm really fast let's see probably not
with this man computers never acted this
way before it's supposed to be a Mac so
in this spectrum went too far sorry in
the spectrum of missions that I was
talking about here we go
so in this spectrum of programs and
there's 10 programs I'm just showing you
3 divisions to kind of keep it organized
going from early stage innovation to
game-changing technology to
cross-cutting capabilities or in other
words going from concept to ground-based
and laboratory testing to flight the
question was where does the
International Space Station fit in and
it's not true that the International
Space Station is only over here because
what I'm talking about when I say from
concept to ground-based testing or
laboratory testing to flight is I'm
talking about the technology itself the
International Space Station is a
laboratory so the International Space
Station could be here depending on the
technology that you're demonstrating I
doubt that you're going to use the
International Space Station much in in
paper studies and systems analysis and
paper studies but you could consider the
International Space Station a laboratory
I do much like you have a laboratory
where you do research here on campus so
it's just it's a laboratory it's a
unique environment it's a unique
laboratory that we can utilize for
technology development the human
research program which is where a lot of
the fundamental science for long-term
human degradation in spaces is known
they they run experiments at the
International Space Station that vary in
TRL from probably TRL of maybe 3 all the
way up to TRL of 6 or so and our
technology developments at the
International Space Station will also
probably span that range there'll be
some things that are more systems that
we're just trying to demonstrate out and
there'll be some things that we take to
the International Space Station
where we're not actually sure it's going
to work and we'll take it up there
because of the unique environment
allocations go to things like from
social technology versus materials
engineering versus medical so just to
make sure everybody heard the question
was how much of our I guess budget goes
to certain disciplines like propulsion
or sensors or structures or avionics or
what-have-you
the answer is it that it depends it
depends on you it depends on the
proposals that we receive because we're
not organized by discipline we're
organized by technology readiness level
and we put out an open call that is open
across disciplines ok
and if the structures community is the
only community that responds then we'll
be very structures heavy but if the
structures and proposing community both
respond equally and they both have
meritorious proposals then we'll be
roughly 50/50 split right so it just
depends on the response
yes so I would actually argue that one
of the problems over the past decade
with NASA is that very little of what
I'm talking about has been done it's not
a matter of the propulsion community is
fat fat and happy and the structures
community is starved
it's that neither community had a place
to take an innovative idea and what
we're trying to provide here is a home
for all of those innovators now I should
mention it's another piece of background
my office created a set of space
technology roadmaps
these are roadmaps that our discipline
based this is why I'm mentioning it in
response to your question there's a
propulsion there's actually a launch
propulsion and an in-space propulsion
roadmap there's a structures and
materials roadmap and and so on and so
on and these roadmaps are now under
control of the National Academy of
Engineering and they're running a decade
will serve a like process where they're
getting the community involved in those
roadmaps NASA produced a rough draft
basically and gave it to the National
Academy and the National Academy is
involving people from all over the
country in reviewing and changing and
editing rewriting basically these
roadmaps they'll be returned to NASA and
we will use them much like the science
Mission Directorate uses the decadal
surveys we'll use them as guidance for
how we make our technology investments
I'm mentioning that because these
roadmaps are being compiled in an open
way if you choose to you could
participate you know there's a website
where you can send comments you can go
to some of the open meetings and speak
up now you could talk about some of your
ideas with the National Academy and they
would be included in the roadmap process
yes sir
students are graduates so with regard to
human spaceflight we want to have the
best impact
who should we go work for who should you
go work for in human spaceflight well of
course I'm going to tell you to go work
for NASA I I'll tell you that I'll tell
you that for real actually so I I need
you know I need to say that NASA has
been extremely important in my own
career I got I was very fortunate I went
to NASA right out of undergraduate
school and it was probably the best
decision I made I could have gone lots
of places and it's at you know those
first few years at NASA Langley set the
whole foundation for my future career I
didn't stay there forever you know I
worked at Langley for a while I left I
went to Georgia Tech now I'm back at
NASA there's absolutely nothing wrong
with going to one of the commercial
human spaceflight hopeful companies but
there's also nothing wrong with going to
work at the Johnson Space Center or the
Marshall Space Flight Center you know
one of the major human space flight
center's of NASA I tell you you know
there's a strong engineering talent at
all of those locations and rather than
me just picking a winner I would say you
know when you go for your interviews you
should be interviewing them and you
should focus on the job that they are
offering you and whatever job speaks to
you in your heart is what you should do
don't do it for the money don't do it
because your friend said company X is
good and company Y is bad do it
for what you know because you're going
to be spending a lot of time working and
if you're going to be spending a lot of
time working you might as well be doing
something you love right so that's what
I would suggest
desire
treating our gems
I don't I don't know a lot about that
actually so we are going to do a lot
I'll tell you we are going to do a lot
in propulsion we're going to do things
that are both
I wouldn't say near-term but just a few
years out and we're gonna do things that
could be twenty to forty years out so
we're gonna span the gamut they're not
just in propulsion but I would say in
materials as well you know we're the you
know obviously for NASA to go from let's
say aluminum or aluminum lithium tanks
very large tanks to composite tanks is a
big step it helps us a lot but to go to
nanotechnology or some of the things out
out beyond that is even a bigger step
and the beauty of the space technology
program is that we will be making a
portfolio of investments some of them
will be more near-term and more focused
some of them will be much more long-term
and visionary thank you sir
[Music]
sure yeah so the the request for
proposals is already out you can find
them on my website that I showed you
earlier some of it one of them is
actually already closed for the students
that are in here they're the first one
that we released was called the space
technology graduate fellowship program
this is a new program that will when it
gets to steady-state will sponsor 500
graduate students in our nation's
universities in areas aligned with one
of the space technology roadmaps that
are opened and it closed in February
we're going to be making awards the
first awards will be announced I think
in early June for students that start in
the fall semester okay
there are currently three solicitations
that are open the NASA Institute for
advanced concepts is something that
existed before it was actually
terminated and we're bringing it back
it's a it's a place where it's an early
stage innovation program that's looking
at twenty to forty year out concepts
that that call is currently open the
game-changing demonstrate game-changing
development call which is one of two
programs and game-changing technology is
currently open and then over here
technology demonstration missions which
is the bi project the largest dollar
value Awards that we'll be making so
where we'll take perhaps have a
dedicated launch and demonstrate some
pretty large technologies in space all
three of those calls are currently open
the calls are going to be an outgoing to
be released on a yearly cycle and so and
we're actually moving pretty quick in a
2012 so while these calls are open and
they'll be closing in the next month or
so
you know they'll they'll be the next set
that come out across all ten programs
yeah so for 2011 the current year we're
using the draft roadmaps that NASA
developed to set to guide us in our
selections the the National Academy
process has two dates associated with it
we're going to have a preliminary report
from the National Academies in September
and we're going to have a final report
in January September 2011 January 2012
so we're actually going to use the space
technology roadmaps returned to us from
the National Academy in the 2012 set of
calls as our our guiding documents if
you will we're going to use them to help
set investment priorities and that that
timing was set up on purpose okay yes
sir in the hopefully the exhibition that
you would look at about STEM education
and didn't hear much about it yes your
office directly well NASA is the office
of education and that office is largely
focused on you know middle school a
little bit you know high school as well
but mostly middle school education my
office is really ramping up in
university education you know what we're
trying to do is we're trying to take
students whether they be undergrad or
grad we start off with graduate students
but long term whether they be
undergraduate or graduate students but
where the students are doing research
we're trying to align those students
research with the space technology
roadmaps and when those things are
aligned we plan to fund those students
fund their stipends or fun fund their
research assistantships so that's you
know that's kind of the dividing line if
you will you know because this program
is focused really on the development of
technologies there's a natural link
there with universities and with
university students and then the office
of education focuses on
not just the middle and high school
students but on educating those teachers
right you know when they can educate a
teacher that teacher has a much greater
impact than they can by just one-on-one
going with the students signing in your
office no am i imagining the entire
undergraduate and graduate portfolio in
my office the answer is no there's
currently well in 2010 most of it was in
the Office of Education and there were
little bits of it in the mission
directors so Aeronautics actually funds
some graduate students the science
Mission Directorate funds some graduate
students and so on and what I'm doing in
space technology is I'm really ramping
up the number of students and the and
frankly the involvement of those
students in NASA work but I don't I do
not expect that the office of education
will get out of that business if that's
what you're asking me I think it'll be a
joint you know for a while at least
it'll be joint and we'll see how it goes
you know what my goal was
my goal was not to take over the
education programs my goal is to get
more students involved in NASA so the
way to get more students involved in
NASA is to have more program right which
is what I'm trying to do okay
Wow some question about that that is
also my job
okay so NASA is doing more and more with
internationals as I mentioned is not a
space race anymore I just use that
phrase it's really a much more of a
collaboration and when it comes to
partnerships whether they be
partnerships with the commercial sector
or partnerships with internationals when
we're talking about technology the
responsibility for those technology
partnerships is in my office and I
actually have I didn't bring my org
chart to be kind of boring but I have an
office sub office in my office that's
focused on technology partnerships
partnerships across the government
partnerships with the commercial sector
and international partnerships and what
those people are doing is they're going
out and they're trying to develop those
partnerships basically we'll go to
country X or other government agency Y
and we try to get a list of technology
priorities from that organization and we
match it up with our list and if there's
a commonality it doesn't have to be that
they're number one thing is our number
one thing but if you know something in
their top five is also in our top five
we then explore that area further and
see if we can leverage each other's
investment and do that together for
technology there are some difficulties
in doing that there's of course ITAR
which you may know something about the
ITAR policy is currently under review
and it's a I'm expecting a revision of
that policy at some point soon I'm not
involved in the review of that policy
but what we're doing right now so for
instance give you an example we're
interested in robotics the Germans are
making major investments there as are we
and so we're keeping each other informed
and the teams are talking to each other
there's no funds that are crossing the
ocean if you will the Germans fund their
folks and we fund our
but we are actually I would say at some
level we are actually leveraging each
other's investment and over time I think
you'll see more and more of that type of
collaboration with other countries okay
thank you thank you
[Applause]